jobs is number one absolutely the greed
of Wall Street that put so many people
into a serious situation I'm here to
fight for the Democrats and also to
fight for my people which is it black
people we've been fighting to defend
public education against what is
honestly an assault on it and an attempt
to privatize one of the most cherished
institutions in America and I'm here as
a member of the socialist contingent
March that marched here and is
participating in the event so that we
can provide more radical alternative to
some of the the ideas being suggested
here Tea Party exists because the
right-wing baizen but a lot of their
membership a lot of the bodies that come
out to their rallies are disaffected
working people their fears their worries
their concerns we share for a large part
we just have a whole different way of
approaching what the solution maybe I
like President Obama like everybody else
you know people have their complaint I
hit into this and you know what I'd like
to see you turn the Titanic around on a
dime and that group never would have had
the traction that it seems to be getting
had there been more real bold leadership
shown by Democrats people don't respond
to ass kissing people respond to
leadership I feel like Obama is doing
I think they're giving him a hard time
it really hasn't hasn't done enough you
know when we talk about health care you
know he puts through this mild reform
bill when you know something that we
really need is single-payer health care
and we support the health care bill we
support the bank bailout because it was
you needed to do it to say of this
country from disaster Obama was tough
when he was running but Obama spent too
much time trying to kiss the Republican
ass every time I turn on the TV Barack
Obama is doing something to help better
education whether it's trying to get
more money or do something for teacher
so I definitely agree with anything with
Barack Obama's doing we must defend
public education because if we don't if
we allow this privatization plan to go
through we are going to have a much more
segregated to ratify two-tier system of
education in our country and that's not
what the majority people want I'll see
wise right now like get the [ __ ] out of
Afghanistan get the [ __ ] out of the rock
we still have a trillion-dollar
expenditure every year on the war
machine complete fiasco and a waste that
continues over from the last
administration and your list of these
guys talk they're idiots they're
complete idiots that's why the Koch
brothers are on there nobody knows who
they are something if they ask the
bottom I'll explain the
multi-billionaire zouk daddy's money man
work day in there right you know if we
just rely on voting for the lesser two
evils this November we're not gonna win
what we need all you some resident gets
it nope not yet maybe after the election
he'll get it that seems to be the only
thing they understand maybe Democrats
need to talk love you they don't talk to
us yet the ass older happy thank you my
brother a mad black man